c'est la décennie de la dernière chance
après une semaine de campagne québec
solidaire passe en mode climat avec sa
vision 2030 c'est le plan le plus
ambitieux une révolution du transport en
commun qui comprend la création de
québec rails et de québec bus pour
relier toutes les villes du québec
l'interdiction de vendre des voitures à
essence serait devancé à 2030 au lieu de
en plus d'imposer une taxe de 15% sur la
vente de véhicules polluants comme les
baies usd l'an prochain je dirais que
c'est un très bon plan de lutte contre
les changements climatiques mais qui en
rappelle un autre
nommément de similarités entre le plan
du parti québécois et celui de québec
solidaire les deux parties ont utilisé
la même firme de modélisation paul st
pierre plamondon s'attaque donc
maintenant à la cac le vrai sujet c'est
pas tant qu'on a besoin de collaboration
sur des choses qui en fait sont dit de
manière très similaire c'est de l'autre
côté quand on voit des partis qui font
des déclarations comme lâchez moi avec
les jeux est à se demander
dans quelle époque il me dit cible les
éléments incontournables de la
décarbonation du secteur du transport et
tout comme le parti québécois québec
solidaire dans le secteur des bâtiments
cible la cotation énergétique des
bâtiments bâtiments plus écoénergétiques
agriculture plus locale une meilleure
gestion des déchets le plan de québec
solidaire prévoit aussi de serrer la vis
aux grands pollueurs le marché du
carbone seraient ajustés à la nouvelle
cible de réduction soit 55 % des ges
d'ici 2030 nous ont redonné des choix
aux gens qui en ont pas et où jacques
amusé les grands pollueurs les ultra
riches se promène en jet privé oui avec
ces gens de
québec solidaire assure que personne ne
perdra son emploi lors de cette
transition verte qui doit coûter 30 6
milliards de dollars pour un premier
mandat dont 29 milliards uniquement pour
le transport collectif issigeac audrey
charbonneau radio canada montréal